their brains are trying to acclimatize
to a level of status that we just
haven't evolved to experience so we
become slightly
[Music]
insane in the hunter gatherer tribes in
which we evolve tens of thousands of
years ago um there were a status game
just like human groups are now and the
more status that you had in those groups
as I
said the better everything got the more
food you got the better food you got the
the um safer your sleeping side
um uh the great your your your access to
your choice of mates so you know it
plugs directly into survival and
reproduction the more status that you
earned in those groups um the better
your chances of survive surviving
reproduction so it's completely in mesed
in the experience of being alive but in
those days you didn't need Fame because
groups were so much smaller everybody
knew everybody there was no such thing
as Fame so the groups were you know you
know a few dozen people so and and um
yeah so and you know you would you might
get reputations as a great Storyteller a
great hunter a great Tu finder whatever
and that would be great but I think what
happened what's happened now is that our
groups you know we're still tribal we
still have these brains that are
pursuing status but the as our groups
have grown bigger the available status
has grown bigger um as we've settled
down and things like private property
and ownership of land have become
possible these you know back in the days
of the hunter gatherer tribe a
successful Hunter might have a you know
necklace of teeth
and that would be his or her claim to
status um now as soon as private
property becomes possible you can have
you can own countries Nations you know
you can become an emperor uh so so so
the the ways in which we can play status
games has massively expanded um since
the end of um since the beginning of
Agriculture really and now kind of in
the days of international media and
social media is expanded yet again so so
our craving for status is was that even
since before we were human you know
animals you know pursue status um uh but
now it's just the the status that's
available is just massively Amplified so
so it becomes a a hugely tempting and
desirous kind of state to be because the
resources uh that we can ACR by being
our status are just unimaginable to
previous generations so Stefan 30 years
ago say if you asked boys at school what
they wanted to be they still wanted to
be successful and have status they'd say
you know I want to be a footballer I
want to be a pop star or I want to be
whatever but they didn't just say I want
to be famous that's what's changed isn't
it and presumably that's because of
social media which has actually
democratized Fame I mean it has allowed
those people to become famous through
YouTube who would never have had the
chance otherwise I guess maybe that's a
good
thing it it it's it's a complex thing
and it's happening on very many levels
so why is that child now Desiring ing to
become a footballer and I and I think
there was a
study in 2009 which said that most
people actually I'm not quite sure the
dates but before when people would say
they would want to be a teacher or a
doctor would that did change and people
wanted to become celebrities but again I
think it's that desire which is
manufactured in some ways you know
because um I mean it's partly a shortcut
you know that you can become um um
famous just for being famous that you
can bypass all the hard work that you
can um get to this elevated place and
again we're going back to this this um
desire in people to be recognized to be
heard to be seen which is basically the
ego which is narcissism but we all have
playing against the desire of the masses
to have someone who they can look and
worship and admire or make fun of but
this idea that it's a kind of symbiotic
relationship they they they both are
needed um but yes now The Gatekeepers
are gone and anyone can become famous
very rapidly and gain a great deal of of
of Fame and Fortune one thing that I
always say and I warn people is like
once you become famous you can't reverse
that the only way out so you should be
very very careful of what you wish for
um Richard Burton described Fame as a
sweet poison that you gulp eagerly at
first and then you loathe for the rest
of your life well this is the Paradox
which you touched on as well Polly isn't
it that you know all these people who
say they want to become famous they've
seen their Idols have nervous breakdowns
get addicted to drugs or alcohol or
whatever that why do they still want to
be famous do you think I mean I think
there's a real feeling of that won't
happen to me I think generally when
people get famous they're really young
and I mean how dared are you at 18 19 20
like you're you know nothing and and
somebody's offering you this thing that
is largely really celebrated um and you
tune out all the addictions and the drug
overdoses and and I think increase also
we up until recently people weren't open
about their mental health so people
didn't necessarily need to die of fame
um of of Overdose and that pressure uh
but they could have a really really hard
time after it and if they weren't
speaking openly about it who knew um I
always think you know I interview pop
stars at the height of their Fame and
then quite often interview them a few
years later and how extraordinary to
Peak at 24 years old and then what are
you doing the rest of your life is this
gentle if you're lucky decline you never
reach the heights you reach at 24 again
and that's actually hideous that's
that's a really difficult thing to
navigate um but I think when you're very
young and somebody's offering you Fame I
don't think you think for one minute the
bad stuff's going to happen to you you
can only see the great stuff also you
are by definition surrounded by a bunch
of people are like this is great because
they're your manager they're your agent
there're a load of people for whom you
can make a lot of money and even if
their intentions are kind of good it's
very hard to separate your uh
appreciation of your Golden Goose client
with their mental health and and their
future prospects I also think for some
people it does work out I think some
people some people I've met um some who
become friends um I think the key to it
is the later it happens the better and I
think when we were talking about
influencers earlier I have noticed and
in a couple of interviews I've done
recently the people who are happiest and
best adjusted with it become famous of
something they like of a product a film
a TV show in one case an actor I
interviewed recently they are so proud
of this thing that has simultaneously
made them famous that they are in a
better state to deal with it because
they feel there is no disconnect between
this agulation they're getting and this
sense that yeah I did something good I
think that's quite often the problem
you're getting adored mindlessly adored
because when you're famous uh you serve
a purpose for your fans mainly you
become this thing that they need this
the icon you become something to Aspire
to you aren't actually who you are it's
incredibly DEH humanizing incredibly
objectifying um so there is this massive
um Chasm between the person you feel
yourself to be and the Adoration you're
getting um and I think marrying those
two is is a real issue for people
however if you've done something you're
really really proud of um it's easier
there's you know you can you can go yeah
no I I deserve at least a little bit of
this this makes sense to me so you have
a sense of of purpose in life you have a
sense of purpose and you have a sense
that you've done something good and so I
talked to an actually there's a show
coming on very soon called the bear
which I don't think is over here yet but
it's done incredibly well in the States
and it's a brilliant brilliant TV show
it's really really good everything about
it good the casting is good the the
Wardrobe is good the lighting is good
the direction the script all of it the
whole cast so the guy that's become the
star the back of it the guy who plays
this main character a chef called the
bear feels like he's part of something
great he's done something good and he is
part of something great and then it
makes sense doesn't it everyone's going
oh my God you're amazing like well yeah
I've I've done I have done something
amazing and that there is something
solid and real in that that I think
really anchor people so in that case
that's a very good segue onto the second
question which is the flip side of that
is whether we should see Fame as a
talent in itself I think it absolutely a
talent it's a skill it's a skill and it
is a psychological disposition I think
so
um I have come to the inclusion
increasingly people are very sneering
about reality TV stars I think reality
TV TV stars have that skill the the ones
that get through the ones that succeed
the ones that kind of have a long game
out of it and a brand extension out of
it and I think maybe we're getting to
the point of society where people who
are very talented but don't have the
emotional disposition to endure Fame and
it is an endurance um can get on with
their talented stuff and let the reality
TV stars and the Instagram influencers
take the flak you know take the
agulation which they are Better Built to
do so I think it is a skill I mean I
think the idea that and I Instagram um
the influenc influencer culture has
undoubted de democratized fame um in a
way that we've never seen before however
the idea that it's an easy route to fame
it's it's so hard you don't have to be
talented you have to work your ass off
you have to have very little feelings of
Shame which most of us I I don't mean
that I don't mean that you're a
Shameless but you do not you do not for
one minute think does anyone care about
my lunch you of course people care about
my lunch and some people do as with the
Kardashians some people do um so it's a
really unique kind of psychological
setup and I think there was a lot of
narcissism in there um I don't think
it's is it healthy don't know they're
not all corrupt um but I think they
possibly take something unpleasant away
from people who don't enjoy it and I
like I have I am in no sense famous I
don't even rate on the alphabet system
but I've had a couple of brushes where
my profile has suddenly spiked for
different reasons um once with the book
I wrote um and I can't I I don't like it
even I got a lot of grief for the book I
write but I also got a lot of good stuff
what I couldn't stand was the attention
I could not stand being that I felt
incredibly self-conscious I felt
incredibly judged I felt this sort of
the weight of other people's ideas of
who I was on me and I found it confusing
I am not built for it um so I think it's
you know it's definitely a psychological
um strength is it a strength it's it's
it's a type anyway yeah yes um so I
think you have to have that I think you
have really have to be prepared to work
very very hard in deed self-promotion is
exhausting and it is endless and it is
all consuming and if you want to go out
you will never again be just as like a
guide to being an Instagram influencer
if you want to go out for a meal with
your friends you can't do that without
taking a picture of you with your
friends so you got to make sure all your
friends are okay about that having a
little chat in the L doing a live stream
putting your food on and if you don't
want to do that if you want to have a
life which which is somewhat private or
somewhat not for you know a performance
then it's out so yeah I mean I think
it's not a talent I think it's a skill
and I think it's a psychology it's like
being in your own Truman Show isn't it
it absolutely is and most of us not most
of us a lot of us don't want that no
will is it a talent in itself well I
just sort of echo what Paulie was saying
really I think it's um it is a talent
but but but it is definitely a
personality type I think you know be
being specific about it and slightly
nerdy is probably somebody who's High
extra version who enjoys attention and
enjoys being around people and you know
gets a buzz out of getting validation
from other people but also I think
people who crave Fame tend to be lower
in the personality trait of agreeability
so disagreeability um correlates with
being very competitive and wanting to
win and I think so high extra
disagreeable which is also you what
something Stephan said that's also
narcissis narcissistic exactly that's
also the person up that predisposes you
to narciss which I think one those those
two things go um hand in hand I mean one
of the interesting things I found when I
was doing my research for my status book
was that when psychologists research our
need for status um they find that it
never tails off so that's why it's
different to things like power so when
you give people a certain amount of
power most people don't want too much
power because it's like you know with
power comes responsibility and lots of
people expecting things from you so most
people like not like the Donald Trumps
of this world but most people have have
a have a limited tolerance for power um
which is perhaps not what you'd expect
but it's not true for status so so so
when psychologist try to find the the
point where our need for status tails
off they can't find it so you're never
going to be satisfied you're never going
to be satisfied so so and what happens I
think is it ratchets up I I think Mo I
think most people said if you want if
you want that level of Fame that Polly
has just described most people just say
no it's sound like a nightmare but I
think in reality what happens is it
ratchets up so you get one little
Victory and and you think and we're very
good at accepting the state that comes
our way we're very good going actually I
do deserve all this attention I do
deserve to be here on this stage and
we're very good at accepting that stuff
and and then we want more you know we
are climatized very quickly to to a
certain level of and we want more and we
want more and we want more and and then
what happens is you enter this feedback
loop so people who are very successful
so very famous celebrities CEOs
politicians world leaders DML Dem
marcoses and Donald Trumps of this world
um their brains are trying to Alim to a
level of status that we just haven't
evolved to experience so we become
slightly insane you go slightly mad you
get the kind of kind of Kanye West
syndrome so yeah I think yeah so I think
it's a personality type and I also think
as as Stephan that is dangerous to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit I a.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas